okay I drove by your store like a week
ago or two weeks ago is it closed yeah
no it's closed for remodeling okay okay
because I drove by and I might everybody
hitting did I miss something the
pentagon's closed I'm like pentagon is
open well it's not open right now but
you're remodeling because I'm like I
know you got Studio there I'm like [ __ ]
baby's moving I don't know no no we in
the back Studio [ __ ] is everything is
there but we remodeling right now we
just kind of it was time to revamp we've
been there for like five years just just
the whole thing you know new clothes new
everything
um but yeah anything yeah I mean you
obviously have the weed uh the uh [ __ ] I
it's a strain it's what's the strain's
name um well I dropped the first one was
lost Angel and then I dropped the strain
called yala Habibi which was kind of
limited see my thing is I really just
dropped strains with like music you know
it's like cross promotion I mean it's
great too and it's great weed you know
I'm tapped in with the right people as
far as that
um so you know well you know your people
know a thing or two about the weed
industry in here in California you know
said my people yeah they're doing
amazing and they open so many doors for
me this whole wheat thing opened the
doors to all these artists for me pretty
much you know what I'm saying yeah and
uh do I just mean like Armenians got
this weird [ __ ] kind of sewed up yeah no
100 strapses and Asians it's not even
kind of the Asians yeah they run yeah
well backpack boys is Asian also we are
immediate of course it's half my people
like literally my actual people yes not
my you know me
um shout out my dogs
um yeah man the weed thing's been
amazing for me but I'm I'm like one foot
in one foot out as far as the weed
business you know what I mean um I'm
trying to get any more but it's kind of
aren't you also like a a certified
pharmacist Yeah by trade yeah I am
and I own a pharmacy in Tarzana
um yeah man that's like the The
Immigrant Armenian thing is like man I
got my hands on some of that Joe Rogan
juice that was sold out everywhere
during the pandemic what was that [ __ ]
about oh Ivermectin remember I grabbed
some off you oh yeah it's like yo you
got that Ivermectin [ __ ] I got you Doug
yeah but uh yeah please don't hit me for
no medication
um because people do all the time I bet
they do but they probably hit you for
some wild [ __ ] yeah they hit me for all
this [ __ ] that kind of [ __ ] is cool yeah
I got some antibiotics but like yo you
can't get perk 30s from me go [ __ ]
yourself yeah please um but I get that
all the time but yeah yeah I'm a
pharmacist too you know what I really I
went to school did all that um while I
was doing music and I realized this
ain't gonna work if I'm one foot and one
foot out you gotta go both feet in on
the rap [ __ ] man I fully went into music
but you know I had my license and I and
I have a amazing partner in the pharmacy
world that's uh you know I mean that
kind of ruins the day-to-day that's
amazing